hi this Mike Flynn for recent TV we are
here in st. Paul for day three of the
Republican convention we are actually
here to reception on beautiful Summit
Avenue the home of all the robber barons
which is appropriate right down the
street is actually where f scott
fitzgerald grew up it's been very
interesting in this third day is that
you really get a sense as a libertarian
that we're being kind of courted by the
Republicans in their platform and their
introduction they actually have a shout
out to libertarians and saying that they
are the party that libertarians can find
home with it's almost like we're kind of
the jilted lover that they realize they
screwed up with and now they're coming
back with all kind of promises for how
they'll change and do different things
and they've really seen the light now
and they'll send us flowers and birthday
cards and remember those important dates
they a lot of the delegates are really
desperate to keep libertarians in the
coalition it's very clear that they they
recognize they need us I think it's
interesting that tonight's lineup for
Sarah Palin's a big speech have so far
been either minorities women or
entrepreneurs which which really kind of
speaks to libertarians because you know
that's why you need the free market is
that so people without means people who
may not have certain advantages can
proceed to prosperity and for that you
need the free market and so to profile
those examples is kind of a wink a bit
to the libertarians I'm still a little
coy about it I'm not sure it's true i
mean when old lover makes new promises
you always have to be a little jilted
but it's been interesting to watch and
we'll see how it plays out